[Musique]
bienvenue dans des bas sur France 24
consacré à cette explosion qui a fait
deux morts hier soir dans un village
polonais à une trentaine de kilomètres
de la frontière ukrainienne les
ambassadeurs de l'OTAN se sont réunis
leur conclusion cette explosion est
vraisemblablement dû à un tir de missile
de la défense aérienne ukrainienne rien
n'indique qu'il s'agisse d'une attaque
délibérée à lancer le secrétaire général
de l'OTAN prudence donc côté occidentale
Joe Biden avait déjà évoqué cette
possibilité la Pologne a donc relevé le
niveau d'alerte de certaines unités
militaires mais à renoncer à
l'activation de l'article 4 de l'OTAN
qui permet des consultations entre pays
membres de l'Alliance atlantique vaudi
mirzuelinski a dit au contraire qu'il
n'y avait aucun doute le missile n'est
pas ukrainien a dit donc un président
ukrainien il y a quelques instants hier
soir veut dire zalinski avait accusé la
Russie d'avoir tiré les missiles sur la
Pologne et évoquer une escalade
importante la Russie avait dément la
journée d'hier a été marquée par une
pluie de bombardements russes sur
l'Ukraine alors que les puissantes ce
monde étaient réunis au G20 à Bali alors
que s'est-il passé cette fameuse nuit de
mardi à mercredi qui a tiré ses missiles
qui ont fait deux morts je vous le
rappelle en Pologne à moins de 35 km de
la frontière ukrainienne c'est incident
est-il un tournant dans la guerre en
Ukraine la prudence des États-Unis et
des Européens permettaient d'éviter
l'engrenage et bien on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés le général Christian Quesnot
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes ancien chef
d'état-major particulier à l'Elysée
bienvenue à vous bienvenue dans le débat
elenaveau le Chine est également avec
nous sur ce plateau bonsoir Elena
journaliste à France 24 spécialiste de
la Russie votre chronique c'est tous les
vendredis à 18h40 c'est vue de Russie et
vous faites le décryptage de la
propagande russe nous avons également
avec nous Claude blanche maison bonsoir
ancien ambassadeur de France en Russie
bienvenue à vous et puis nous avons en
direct de BBC Régis jante bon Régis
correspondant à bilicides donc en
Géorgie spécialiste des anciennes
républiques soviétiques vous êtes
correspondant pour France 24 et RFI et
puis co-auteur avec Stéphane suhan de
volodi mirzelinski dans la tête d'un
héros merci d'être avec nous Régis
selon l'OTAN l'explosion en Pologne a
donc été vraisemblablement et due à un
tir de missile de défense aérienne
ukrainienne on va revenir justement
d'abord en images sur les dernières
déclarations de l'OTAN sur celle des
Européens et puis sur cette nuit pendant
laquelle un engrenage aurait pu être
possible Florent Renaud
c'est la question qui agite la planète
depuis hier soir la Russie a-t-elle fait
basculer le conflit en Ukraine dans une
toute autre dimension en attaquant la
Pologne pays membres de l'OTAN pour
l'Alliance atlantique à ce stade la
réponse est non
suggère que l'incident a probablement
été causé par un missile entier aérien
ukrainien
ce n'est pas la faute de l'Ukraine
la Russie emporte la responsabilité
totale elle qui continue sa guérit
légale contre l'Ukraine
même son de cloche à Varsovie ou le
président polonais l'assure se sont a
priori les Ukrainiens qui ont tiré le
missile à l'origine de la mort de deux
personnes dans le village polonais de
prévau situé à seulement 6 km au nord de
leur frontières le tout premier incident
de ce type sur le sol de l'OTAN depuis
le début de la guerre le 24 février
dernier
absolument rien dit qu'il s'agit d'une
attaque intentionnelle contre la Pologne
à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons aucune
preuve qu'il s'agit d'un missile tiré
par la partie russe mais il y a une
forte probabilité qu'il s'agisse d'un
missile utilisé par les forces de
défense ukrainienne de son côté Moscou
qui attiré mardi une centaine de
missiles en direction de l'Ukraine ni
tout implication dans cet incident
précis et accuse le camp adverse de
provocation délibérée
nous tenons à souligner que des frappes
de haute précision ont été menées et
contre des cibles situées uniquement sur
le territoire de l'Ukraine à moins de 35
km de la frontière avec la Pologne
de nombreux dirigeants mondiaux ont
exprimé leur solidarité avec la Pologne
a commencé par volodynersky le président
ukrainien qui désire accusait sans
réserve la Russie de Vladimir Poutine
Claude blanche maison ça aurait pu être
l'incident qui débouchait sur un
engrenage sur une troisième guerre
mondiale on peut le dire comme ça c'est
un peu branle bal combat dans les
chancellerie pendant cette nuit oui je
crois que la température à monter très
rapidement hier
effectivement c'était une journée assez
sombre puisque la Russie avait décidé de
bombarder massivement les villes des
objectifs civils
Ukrainiens notamment les alimentations
électriques chauffage etc et entre 80 et
90 missiles ont été retirer dans la
journée ce qui est énorme parallèlement
à ça on l'a pas beaucoup dit mais
Poutine a fait un discours absolument
belliciste où il a exalté le rôle de
l'Union soviétique pendant la grande
guerre patriotique et en gros suggérait
que la signification n'avait jamais été
achevée et que lui achevait le job en
Ukraine donc un discours extrêmement dur
et violent offensif comme comme toile de
fond et ce tir si effectivement il avait
atteint ce qui est le cas donc la
Pologne là et que ça avait été un tir
russe donc ce qui n'est plus là ce qui
n'est pas avéré ça aurait été pour
quelle raison la Russie aurait fait cela
contre un pays de l'OTAN ça aurait été
enfin je veux dire une absurdité totale
déjà que déjà le discours de Poutine et
les frappes les 90 frappes sur l'Ukraine
c'était déjà beaucoup dans dans aucun
moment vous êtes inquiété pendant la
nuit
les dirigeants du monde étaient réunis a
été réuni au G20 Poutine ayant refusé
d'aller au G20 donc c'était quand même
déjà beaucoup je vois pas pourquoi la
Russie aurait choisi ce jour-là pour
frapper à 6 km à l'intérieur de la
Pologne
collatéral peut toujours arriver avec
avec une fusée russe à des gagne quoi
latérale peut toujours arriver avec une
fusée russe mais là c'est je parle sur
le contrôle du général évidemment et on
nous dit que ça n'est pas une fusée
russe que c'est une fusée une fusée
anti-fusée en réalité que les Ukrainiens
aurait tiré et dont le trajet aurait été
dévié par des éléments électroniques ou
autres et qui aurait abouti finalement
serait très bien plus être une fusée
russe en effet qui aurait dysfonctionné
bien sûr les conséquences auraient été
différentes non parce que évidemment ça
n'aurait pas été forcément l'ascension
extrême mais l'OTAN ce serait réuni
comme il l'a fait aujourd'hui et aurait
décidé de mesures à prendre pour réagir
ce qui est frappant c'est que les
États-Unis comme l'OTAN ont gardé un
grand calme dans cette affaire c'est ça
qui est intéressant on va y revenir
général keno est-ce que est-ce que vous
attendiez finalement assez conclusions
lors de cette réunion de l'OTAN
aujourd'hui à Bruxelles qui dit donc ce
sont bien des tirs donc du système de
défense anti-aérien
ukrainien
si vous voulez moi ça m'a pas vraiment
inquiété parce que les
Ukrainiens utilisent des systèmes
d'Armentières qui sont russes sont les
mêmes mais ils ont donc et là moi je
pense entendre la fin de l'histoire mais
je pense on n'a pas encore la fin de
l'histoire parce que cette
ce tir de S300 de mon point de vue à
peut-être atteint la fusée russe qui
devait atterrir normalement en
Ukraine donc
ce qui compte c'est quand on va examiner
les débris s'il y a
uniquement des débris de S300 on peut
estimer que le ça mâle fonctionné que
l'électronique n'a pas fonctionné ou
qu'elle a été perturbée et que cette
cette antiérienne a été déviée et tombé
en Pologne deuxième hypothèse et là
atteint une fusée russe qui devait
arriver normalement en Ukraine et de
l'analyse des débrisions trouve à la
fois des débris de S300 et des débris
d'une fusée russe c'est tout à fait
autre chose alors ça voudrait dire quoi
ça voulait ça voudrait dire que cette
que c'est un acte de légitime défense de
l'Ukraine qui s'est mal terminé pour
deux polonais mais on ne peut en
vouloir à l'Ukraine de ça parce que
n'oublions pas que ce soit même les
Russes qui ont tiré 85 missiles dans la
nuit les conséquences faudrait
probablement été différentes à Elena
vous étiez avec nous sur ce plateau hier
et c'est en sortant de ce plateau qu'on
a vu effectivement en Pologne les Russes
ont démenti assez vite mais vous le dit
mirzelins qui lui a une communication au
contraire assez offensive en disant que
les fusées donc provenaient de Russie on
a frôlé enfin il y a eu quand même de
l'inquiétude cette nuit oui
effectivement on a pensé à une
éventuelle bavure parce que la question
de l'application de ce fameux article 5
de la de la convention de l'OTAN qui est
la défense de tous les États membres
lorsqu'un État membre est agressé c'est
celle de l'intention c'est-à-dire est-ce
qu'il y avait l'intention d'attaquer le
territoire polonais par la Russie ou pas
je pense que on est très vite arrivés à
la conclusion que quel que soit
l'origine de celui-ci il n'y avait pas
de de d'intention russe d'attaquer la
Pologne et au-delà de cela les débris
montreraient effectivement qu'il
s'agirait d'un d'un missile de défense
anti-aérienne ukrainien il y a eu un
vrai paradoxe et un vrai décalage dans
le discours russe qui depuis le début de
la guerre nous dit c'est une guerre de
l'OTAN contre la Russie sur le
territoire ukrainien c'est une guerre
comme elle les Occidentaux etc qui
encourage qui met de l'huile tout le feu
sur le feu sans cesse avec ce discours
en disant que c'est une guerre de l'OTAN
contre la Russie et qui de l'autre côté
prendrait sans doute gardes à ce que ce
conflit ne dégénère à ce qu'il ne
s'étendent parce que je pense que ce
font ce que voudrait au fond dans
l'absolu les Russes c'est que tout le
monde se retire de cette guerre qu'on
laisse cette guerre a une guerre entre
la Russie et
l'ukrainement
s'élargissent et Vladimir Poutine s'il
parle tout le temps et sa propagande
s'il parle tout le temps de guerre de
l'OTAN contre la Russie c'est parce que
ils veulent que les Occidentaux cessent
de livrer des armes à l'Ukraine ils
veulent que les Occidentaux abandonnent
l'Ukraine pour que l'Ukraine capitule
fasse à la Russie donc ils n'ont en fait
aucun intérêt à et pas les moyens
surtout en ce moment alors qu'ils
viennent de se retirer de Kerson
d'élargir détendre le conflit Régis
c'est vous qui êtes bilici quels ont été
les réactions en Géorgie et puis aussi
un mot sur la Pologne qui a été dont on
a salué en fait la communication
prudente
assez peu de réactions ici parce que je
crois que comme tout le monde on a on a
compris assez vite qu'effectivement
enfin on avait quelques informations qui
montraient qu'il y avait probablement
pas l'intention très vite des
journalistes polonais enfin très vite
peut-être une heure une heure et demie
après la première information qu'on
avait trouvé des débris aussi d'amitié
ukrainien ce qui laissait qui ouvrait la
possibilité d'une hypothèse telle que si
ce sont des ici il y a aussi des
fragments de missiles russes c'est qu'il
a peut-être été détruit par un autre
ukrainien donc assez vite assez vite
rassuré malgré tout je crois ensuite sur
la communication c'est surtout celle des
Américains je crois que ça a déjà été
dit qui a été extrêmement prudente qui a
demandé de d'attendre etc la
communication polonaise et puis celle
des pays baltes était un peu plus un peu
plus offensive si je puis dire en tout
cas tu es plus prompte à blâmer la
Russie mais elle restait modérée malgré
tout
en tout cas je le disais avait affirmé
que c'était les Russes on va l'écouter
c'était donc hier soir
de l'OTAN est une attaque russe contre
la sécurité collective c'est une
escalade très importante nous devons
agir je veux dire maintenant à tous nos
frères et sœurs polonais l'Ukraine vous
soutiendra toujours les gens libres ne
seront pas brisés par la terreur
ski qui dit que ça n'est pas justement
un missile ukrainien qu'est-ce que ça
signifie Claude blanche maison est-ce
que d'abord c'est une erreur de
communication de la part des alinski je
ne crois pas je crois que dans son rôle
il est un chef de guerre le chef de
guerre d'un pays qui est agressé par un
très grand pays qui était la Russie et
il parle le soir du jour il a reçu 90
missiles sur dans les villes dans les
villes ukrainiennes par conséquent c'est
assez logique que sa réaction sa
première réaction soit celle-là voilà il
y a une explosion à 6 km à l'intérieur
de la Pologne c'est probablement en
effet d'origine d'origine russe c'est
assez logique est-ce qu'il va s'excuser
en tout cas que ça n'est pas que ce sont
pas les Ukrainiens ce n'est pas un
missile alors ça c'était beaucoup plus
curieux c'est aujourd'hui
la question était est-ce qu'il va
rectifier sa communication peut-être
même se raviser s'excuser en disant je
me suis trompé moi je ne crois pas il va
passer à autre chose demain parce que
tous les jours il se passe un élément
nouveau et on n'attend pas de lui qu'il
fasse les résultats de l'enquête c'est à
l'OTAN de faire les résultats de
l'enquête puisque la question c'était de
savoir si ça déclencher un dispositif de
solidarité de l'OTAN ou pas lui n'est
pas dans l'OTAN donc c'est pas son
problème c'est-à-dire la vérité générale
keno donc il va y avoir une enquête au
sein de l'OTAN comment ça je pense alors
les résultats quels seront le résultat
il n'est pas certain que cette enquête
dise véritablement la vérité pour
des raisons je dirais politique les donc
il y a une enquête mais elle sera pas
fiable
jusqu'à preuve du contraire je n'en sais
rien mais j'ai toujours je suis un peu
sceptique moi de toute ce dans les
genres d'enquête donc si les la
l'enquête de l'OTAN trouve uniquement le
missile de des traces de de S300 bon
c'est et pour le dire si elle trouve
aussi des traces de de missile russe qui
de mon point de vue ça ne serait pas
tout à fait faux parce que quand on
regarde l'impact qu'a eu lieu en Pologne
le cratère est très important on voit
les véhicules qui sont retournés et tout
je me demande si techniquement seul une
charge de S300 pourrait arriver à ce
résultat
donc je pense moi que cette mais je me
trompe certainement peut-être mais je
pense que l'impact et l'explosion est
lié à la fois au S300 et au missile
russe qui a été abattu par le S300 donc
ça serait un peu le oui on peut dire une
sorte de conséquence de de cette pluie
de missiles qui a eu lieu hier pendant
la journée en tout cas l'Ukraine demande
un accès immédiat au site donc il
voudrait être présent lors de cette
enquête Elena en parlait justement de la
du discours de Vladimir Poutine est-ce
qu'il est toujours aux commandes c'est
quand même une question qu'on se pose je
pense que vous Vladimir Poutine est en
très très grosse difficulté depuis le
retrait de Carson on l'entend sur le
discours officiel dans ce des chaînes de
télévision des propagandistes qui se
divisent qui se divisent sur le sujet le
fait que ce sont les militaires qui ont
annoncé ce retrait en la personne du
ministre de la défense et du général
Sergueï sur viking qui commande les
opérations en Ukraine je pense que la
vladim routine sa réalité parallèle est
dépassée par la réalité du terrain à
savoir que il a eu vite fait étoffé
d'annoncer l'annexion de quatre régions
ukrainiennes dont deux nouvelles mon
conquises suite à cela la réalité en
fait militaire tout simplement de la
conquête ne suit pas du tout derrière
donc là effectivement il est en retrait
il est en difficulté il y aurait il est
ce que ça veut dire que quelqu'un
d'autre pourrait éventuellement lui
succéder enfin il y a une question alors
je pense que là
on va très très vite évidemment la
question de la succession de le dire
Poutine se pose dès lors que se pose la
caisselle de de son régime de la survie
de son régime du fait parce que lui-même
et sa propagande nom de cesse de dire
que on doit aller jusqu'au bout et on
doit gagner cette guerre il en va de la
survie de la Russie et on entend par là
le fait que Vladimir Poutine ça m'a Amal
amalgamant sa personne à l'existence
même du pays et et à la personne si je
puis dire de la Russie il ne voit pas la
Russie survivre en tout cas il ne veut
pas que l'on entendent une Russie qui ex
qui existerait sans son pouvoir donc à
ce point de vue là lui-même à partir du
moment où il est en train de perdre si
on ne s'avance pas trop en disant cela
et je pense que l'on s'avance toujours
un petit peu trop à mon sens dans le
temps médiatique mais enfin supposons
qu'il est qu'il est en grande difficulté
dans ce conflit actuellement il est
aussi et il se sent sans doute menacé
fragilisé et on entend encore une fois
j'en reviens au discours de propagande
parce que d'abord c'est mon fond de
commerce et ensuite on peut entendre et
lire beaucoup de choses en écoutant la
propagande russe on entend beaucoup
beaucoup d'appels de ceux qui
s'accrochent au camp Poutine des de ses
plus proches alliés de ses plus proches
partisans à se rassembler à faire bloc à
se réunir à ne surtout pas se diviser
c'est le signe que le colosse a les
pieds d'argile qui qui flanchent Claude
devant chez eux peut-être réagir
là-dessus en tout cas ils ont pilonné
hier et d'après justement les Américains
d'après le Miss de la Défense américain
les systèmes américains d'interception
donc les fameux NASA m'ont réussi à 100%
d'interception donc de missiles russes
ils ont intercepté 17 missiles russes et
dideronnes iranien donc là ça montre
tout de même à quel point les rues sont
bombardées hier donc bien sûr c'était
terrible pour les Ukrainiens mais en
même temps il s'épuise ça montre aussi
la vulnérabilité russe non et une grande
inefficacité en plus je pense que ce qui
s'est passé au G20 est assez grave pour
Poutine parce que ça a montré que d'une
certaine façon les Chinois enfin les
plus proches des briques par rapport à
la Russie et était en train de prendre
leur distance alors pas de le lâcher
complètement mais de prendre leur
distance et de le faire savoir se
communiquer du G20 on pensait qu'il n'y
en aurait pas tout le monde pensait que
il serait bloqué par un véto russe par
un veto chinois
pas du tout et en réalité alors en plus
autre symbole Poutine refusant d'y aller
pour diverses raisons envoie la brosse
lavrof les Indonésiens disent il a eu un
malaise on l'a on a mis à l'hôpital et
aussitôt comme rein du Kre dans la bonne
tradition soviétique c'est faux il va
très bien d'ailleurs voilà la vidéo et
on le voit sur ça sur sa terrasse en
train de prendre le thé avec un t-shirt
d'un magasin à la mode à New York si je
comprends bien et puis il est parti il
est parti un jour avant la fin et ce
qu'il est parti alors autre communiqué
du Kremlin disant mais ça a toujours été
prévu il ne devait pas rester le dernier
jour il y avait pour cela le ministre
des Finances peut-être a-t-il été
rappelé peut-être a-t-il été rappelé
hier soir on n'en sait rien en tout cas
c'est une défaite pour Poutine que ce
communiqué était adopté avec une assez
grande habilité de la présidence
indonésienne une grande majorité des
pays présents c'est de l'expression
c'est pas l'unanimité c'est une grande
majorité des pays présents et ensuite on
condamne la guerre on on
récuse naturellement toute touche
chantage nucléaire touche chantage
alimentaire touchantage énergétique
c'est-à-dire tous les sujets qui qui
occupent Poutine ça montre l'isolement
de la Russie Régis vous qui avez écrit
un livre qui s'appelle dans la tête de
volo diversel inscrit qu'est-ce qu'il
avait lorsqu'il a communiqué aussi
rapidement en disant que c'était les
Russes
je pense que comme vous le soulignez
tout à l'heure il y avait effectivement
c'était une très difficile journée hier
avec notamment beaucoup d'attaques sur
des sites civils et puis sur des
infrastructures électriques et ça
pénalise véritablement le pays donc je
crois que Zelinski a fait de la
communication assez efficace et il n'a
pas voulu s'ennuyer si je veux dire avec
des détails et ce qu'il a voulu
souligner en forçant très peut-être
c'est de dire et bien de toute façon les
Russes ne devraient pas être là donc peu
importe que le missile qui est tombé sur
la Pologne soit
ukrainien russe ou autre ce qui est
important c'est que les Russes n'avaient
rien à faire là et si les Russes
n'étaient pas là il aurait pas eu à le
faire à le faire tomber je crois que
c'est quelque chose de contradiction
Régis avec justement la communication
américaine avec ses alliés
oui mais au fond pour lui je pense que
c'est pas c'est pas très important je
crois que c'est une manière de condamner
au fond la présence russe et la guerre
que mène la Russie et puis peu importe
comme le disait l'ambassadeur blanche
maison demain il va passer à autre chose
parce que parce que il y aura d'autres
choses et puis et puis on oubliera et ça
ne le pénalisera pas en tout cas les
Ukrainiens ne vont pas oublier cette
journée d'hier dont on parlait
puisqu'elle a été marqué par la
multiplication de ces bombardements
russes une centaine de missiles donc ils
se sont abattus contre les réseaux
énergétiques de l'Ukraine des coupures
de courant dans la moitié du pays
jusqu'en Moldavie on va regarder ce
reportage on envoyait spéciaux à Nicolas
IV à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
Carson Carson donc qui vous le savez a
été reprise par les Ukrainiens
aux abords de mikolaiev Yuri nous
présente sa maison
avec sa femme et ses deux filles
[Musique]
on était plus en sécurité ici quand les
Russes nous lâchaient des bombes à
fragmentation
mais si un missile laisse 300 frappes un
garage comme celui-ci peut devenir un
cercueil
avec deux générateurs des réservants nos
du chauffage et des lits en palettes
l'endroit est aussi confortable que
possible
ces filles de 12 et 13 ans suivent leur
cours en ligne
on a acheté une télé pour les enfants
c'est ici qu'ils étudient les enfants
semblent s'être habitués c'est bien ici
c'est confortable et j'ai pris
l'habitude une seule chose leur manque
mes animaux me manquent
et quoi d'autre
rien pour leur mère tout a été chamboulé
c'est huit derniers mois elle regarde le
retrait des troupes russes de Carson
avec méfiance
il pourrait y avoir de graves
conséquences il pourrait lâcher une
sorte de bon sur nous c'est comme s'ils
avaient retiré leurs hommes et évacuer
pour libérer le territoire et il
pourrait commencer à nous bombarder
c'est de ça dont j'ai peur une dizaine
d'autres familles vit dans les mêmes
conditions dans ce quartier toute espère
regagner leur maison à temps pour y
célébrer le nouvel an
général keno donc on voit qu'il se
prépare à l'hiver dans quelle mesure à
votre avis les l'armée russe est-elle en
difficulté hier ils ont abandonné Nova
kafkovka donc enfin les autorités
d'occupation ils sont donc sous le
Nièvre aujourd'hui ou est-ce qu'on en
est alors les
Russes étant en grande difficulté c'est
si je vais répondre aux questions mais
je vais revenir sur les histoires de
missiles qui ont été tirés et donc où
les tirs de précision américain on a
battent quand même un certain nombre et
on sait que
l'industrie russe peut en produire entre
150 et 200 par an donc
d'armement le type le type de missile
qui sont qui sont tirés actuellement sur
l'Ukraine donc il va il va se poser à un
moment à un problème de un problème de
stock et d'autant plus comme comme il y
a le l'embargo sur tout ce qui est puce
et tout ce qui est électronique les
qui ont du mal à équiper leurs missile
d'une électronique de bonne qualité donc
là à terme surtout que les Américains
renforcent encore la défense
entièreienne donc cette idée de l'armée
russe de faire plier la population
ukrainienne en détruisant l'eau en
détruisant l'électricité à mon avis ne
va pas marcher
alors qu'est-ce qui reste il reste les
forces les forces terrestres qui sont
pas en très bonne posture les les Russes
ont fait sur la rive gauche du niep 3
zones de défense et le
il essaie difficile aux Ukrainiens de
faire des franchissements en fibi pour
les attaquer de face moi je serai le
général en chef ukrainien c'est pas ce
que je ferais et je pense que l'idée les
Ukrainiens ont déjà pas mal de troupes
sur la rive gauche et avec les renforts
il y a 50 chars qui vont arriver qui ont
été par les Américains qui ont encore 50
qui sont prévus ils vont avoir les
moyens quand le sol va être gelé de
mener une contre-attaque qui prendrait
les les lignes de défense par le travers
et donc à ce moment-là elle ne sert plus
à rien parce que tout de même pour les
Ukrainiens non ce que vous décrivez
si vous voulez c'est une pour moi c'est
une c'est une manœuvre intelligente ils
ont la capacité de le faire et de et de
le planifier aussi avec les
désaméricains ils auront tout leur
renseignement pour savoir peuvent avoir
des contre-attaques ou non donc c'est ça
me semble une solution donc les Russes
perdent les Russes moi je pense que à
terme les Russes perdent et ce qui amène
les discussions qu'on évoquées au sein
de la Russie de du remplacement de
remplacement de Poutine et là il y a
deux hypothèses parce que c'est soit le
FSB soit l'armée parce que ni le FSB ni
l'armée ne veulent porter le chapeau de
de cet échec parce que le FSB n'a pas
donné quand même les bons renseignements
apotine ou les a pas reçu au départ et
aucun des deux ne veut porter le chapeau
donc la le remplacement à la tête se
fera soit par un général du du FSB soit
par un général de l'armée d'autant que
les discussions se poursuivent entre ça
major américain est à major russe et je
suis sûr qu'il parle déjà de ce sujet
Elena veut réagir peut-être
hypothèse très personnelle c'est qu'on
ne va pas avoir une jambe au pouvoir ou
un représentant des services ou
peut-être un ancien en tout cas mais
dans tous les cas ce la tradition dans
ces cas-là voudrait que ce sera soit
plutôt un apparatif c'est-à-dire un
fonctionnaire quelqu'un du civil qui
soit c'est à dire qu'on garde un pays
qui est dirigé comme il est maintenant
par les services mais avec Vladimir
Poutine qui d'ailleurs est un ancien des
services ancien du kg lorsqu'il devient
plus vite
donc avec quelqu'un qui qui vient des
services avec un pays qui est dirigé par
les services mais en tout cas avec
quelqu'un qui aura un Carné le pouvoir
pendant plus de 20 ans comme Vladimir
Poutine de façon extrêmement forte et
unique en mode quasi pilotage manuel
pour tout ce qui est de la moindre petit
plus petite décision qui est prise à
l'autre bout du pays quelqu'un donc du
système en fait vraiment du sérail non
oui enfin ou alors quelqu'un que
personne ne connaît un peu comme le
premier ministre Michaël michoustine a
remplacé le premier le mitry-médetv qui
est devenu chef du Conseil de sécurité
si vous voulez donc c'est ce qui se
passe dans ces traditions autocratiques
c'est ce qui s'est passé dans les pays
d'Asie centrale lorsque par exemple en
Ouzbékistan lorsque voilà après 20 ans
30 ans de règne de d'un dictateur on
peut le dire aujourd'hui c'est quelqu'un
de finalement absolument gris connu
inconnu au bataillon qui arrive au
pouvoir avec un pays qui sera dirigé
pendant je ne sais pas 10 - 30 ans par
papa par les services parce que par en
revanche je ne crois pas à la chute du
régime enfin en tout cas dans ces dans
ces rouages tel qu'il est dirigé
aujourd'hui par les salariés un scénario
à la Dimitri medve par exemple ça s'est
exclu oui oui parce que ça veut dire
c'était désigné par Poutine pour tenir
le siège chaud en attendant le retour de
Poutine et MDF restaient aux ordres de
Poutine c'est un fond de pouvoir en
quelque sorte non je pense que
effectivement un jour mais je pense que
ce jour n'est pas si proche que cela il
y aura une révolution de palais une
révolution de palais en effet puisque la
Lépine dorsale de ce régime c'est les
services de sécurité et notamment le FSB
le plus puissant d'entre eux c'est
probablement entre ces services et
l'armée que ce négociera en effet la
personne qui donnera toute garantie
alors ça sera pas forcément l'un d'entre
eux ça pourrait quand même être l'un
d'entre eux mais en effet il y a des tas
de gens au Kremlin et parmi les
gouverneurs qui pourraient tout à fait
faire l'affaire on cite souvent alors
bien sûr la Constitution dit que de
toute façon en cas d'empêchement du
président c'est le premier ministre qui
fait l'intérim donc fameux mes choses
qui ne parle jamais de la guerre qui ne
parle jamais de la guerre lui gère le
pays et c'est un technocrate ancien
directeur général des impôts on parle
aussi parfois du du maire de Moscou qui
a très bien géré sa ville pendant le
confinement plutôt mieux que plutôt
mieux que le que le pays et qui en effet
présente toutes les garanties du point
de vue des services de sécurité un
proche de Poutine est un bon qui est un
bon gestionnaire et bien sûr bien sûr il
a dirigé l'administration présidentielle
mais il y a un autre il y a quelqu'un
qui est le numéro 2 de l'administration
présidentielle qui à l'époque où moi
j'étais en Russie passait pour un
hyperlibéral d'ailleurs il avait été
premier ministre hyper libéral de
yelcine il avait échoué t'avais pas duré
très longtemps ça avait été une faillite
financière mais il a dirigé rosatum qui
est une grande entreprise qui comporte
qui est gère tout le civil tout le
nucléaire civil et militaire pendant 10
ans donc il a des capacités
effectivement administratives et il est
le numéro 2 du Kremlin alors aujourd'hui
il est devenu dur pour donner des gaz
naturellement mais je crois que c'est
une compétition en effet pour donner des
gages à ceux qui sont les faiseurs de
roi Régis chanter
il y a une compétition
oui certainement même si on en voit
assez peu les prémices pour le moment
mais c'est ce qui vient d'être dit plus
ou moins c'est qu'on a on n'a pas de
signe qui nous montre que clairement en
ce moment la lutte est véritablement
engagée on sait qu'il y a plein de gens
qui sont contre c'est plutôt les gens
qui gèrent qui gèrent de l'argent soit
dans le privé soit dans le public qui
sont plutôt cons parce qu'ils voient
combien ça ça affecte l'économie
c'est-à-dire qui caractérise ce régime
ça a été une vraie concentration du
pouvoir notamment après l'élection de la
criminaire 2014 où on sait à ce
moment-là que le cercle décisionnel
c'est véritablement réduit et c'est
concentré autour de Monsieur Poutine et
quelques personnes des services de
sécurité en effet puis un ami proche
très proche de Monsieur Poutine qui
s'appelle yourikovachu très qui est
vraiment très important un peu à une
sorte de l'idéologue un ami idéologue
très conservateur etc et puis ça
continue ensuite à se concentrer
véritablement juste à jusqu'au Conseil
de sécurité le fameux du 21 février
dernier où là on avait vraiment
l'impression d'avoir affaire à une
autocratie puisque c'était simplement
une mise en scène d'une décision qui
avait été prise à l'avance par par
Monsieur Poutine après effectivement
tous les scénarios sont possibles et ça
dépendra beaucoup du résultat de la
guerre effectivement s'il y a une
défaite cuisante il est fort possible
que les amis de Monsieur Poutine se
retournent contre lui et lui fasse
porter le chapeau peut-être pour mieux
sauver le régime ce qui est le
caractérise encore une fois et j'ai pas
mal travaillé ces derniers mois sur sur
ce sujet on voit c'est une vraie
concentration l'élite dirigeantes les
cercles dirigeants qui sont actuellement
autour de Monsieur Poutine ont vraiment
été façonné par lui pour la plupart ou
bien vraiment mise au pas comme
l'ancienne oligarchie qui n'a plus
véritablement de de pouvoir donc c'est
vraiment des gens qui doivent leur
pouvoir à Monsieur Poutine avec une
colonne vertébrale comme ça vient d'être
rappelé qui est celle des cilos VIKids
celle des structures de force j'ai fait
récemment un classement sur les 100
personnes qu'on considère comme à peu
près les plus influentes de Russie et il
se trouve qu'il y avait 37 qui soit ont
une formation dans les services de
sécurité ou bien qui occupent des postes
de type sécuritaire aujourd'hui mais
alors du coup il pourrait trahir Poutine
Elena d'après ce que dit Régis si
effectivement tout est archi organisé
qui lui doivent tout oui je pense parce
qu'aujourd'hui chacun a conscience que
Vladimir Poutine est en train de faire
couler le navire après pourquoi je ne
crois pas un mitry-medef ou même un
sergueil qui est le monsieur Ukraine de
la le monsieur stratégie Ukraine du
Kremlin parce que il y a une chose très
simple qui qu'il ne faut pas perdre de
vue c'est que au lendemain de la
prétendue chute de Vladimir Poutine il y
aura la bataille de l'opinion une
opinion qui même sur fond de
d'artificiel soutien à Vladimir Poutine
son opération spéciale etc il croit
absolument plus et complètement laminé
donc il y aura juste une opération
populiste qui visera tout simplement à
faire croire qu'on fait table rase du
passé et qu'on recommence tout à zéro
donc il faudra soit un inconnu parfait
au bataillon soit un libéral ça ne sera
certainement pas de mitry-médoc qui a
certainement cette velléité parce qu'il
est plus royaliste que le roi depuis le
début de la guerre et qu'il prône le
rétablissement de la peine de mort etc
mais il y aura une volonté des forces
qui vont mettre en place la transition
jusqu'à ce que l'on trouve quelqu'un qui
soit qui qui gagnera la guerre des clans
soit qui sera
qui a de nouveau aura une main de faire
cette période de transition il faudra
quelqu'un qui représente un renouveau
libéral où on va jouer sur ce discours
de de d'ouverture de la société une
sorte de glace Beast ou de
périostroïques à bises si vous voulez
après le régime de Poutine Dimitri medle
ce qui avait mis le faux aux poudres en
2012 lorsque il y a eu ce qu'on appelait
la marge du million des centaines de
milliers de personnes dans les rues
russes qui ont manifesté c'est parce que
il y avait de nouveau eu cette inversion
entre maître vedev et Poutine on ne va
pas remettre un mètre def derrière pour
reprovoquer cela je pense que il y a eu
des erreurs des des des pardon des
leçons qui ont été tirées des erreurs et
on va essayer de reconquérir l'opinion
russe ce qui sera très facile parce
qu'il y aura de nouveau une propagande
mais une propagande à l'envers vous
dites l'opinion russe en fait les Russes
ne soutiennent pas ce conflit c'est ce
que vous dites Elena aujourd'hui il y a
plus vraiment de questions il
soutiennent mais ils soutiennent si vous
voulez par défaut c'est à dire que dès
le lendemain de de lorsque ce discours
sera terminé comme quoi il faut des
nazifier l'Ukraine etc lorsqu'il y aura
un autre discours qui sera servi
l'opinion publique russe si vous voulez
n'en est tellement pas une elle est
tellement habituée à suivre les discours
officiels que elle acceptera avec autant
de docilités le nouveau discours qui
sera service c'est en cela que je dis
qu'il ne croit pas fondament
fondamentalement à ses discours après
évidemment en apparence et
artificiellement le soutien à la
dénazification entre guillemets de
l'Ukraine continue à être extrêmement
fort malgré la mobilisation
les protestations des mers russes qui ne
jusqu'ici on entendait pas parce que bon
les enfants tués étaient payés 70 000
euros quoi enfin mais ça commence à
venir donc on en est pas à ce qui est
s'était passé en
encore les Russes se sont retirés
d'Afghanistan sous la pression des mers
russes on en est pas là mais c'est un
facteur qui qui monte petit à petit en
puissance le G20 en tout cas il vous le
disiez Monsieur l'Ambassadeur a montré
l'isolement de la Russie puisqu'il y a
eu donc ce communiqué qui inclut le
terme de guerre un texte qui note que la
plupart des membres du G20 ont condamné
fermement la guerre en Ukraine je cite
le communiqué un communiqué qui appelle
également à l'extension d'un accord pour
l'exportation des céréales des portes
Ukrainiens de la mer Noire un accord qui
s'interrompt d'ailleurs vendredi on va
écouter Emmanuel Macron c'était donc à
la toute fin de ce G20 aujourd'hui
le G20 n'a pas détourné le regard de la
guerre en Ukraine bien au contraire
nos débats sur la base d'ailleurs de
propositions que nous avions faites
montrent qu'il existe un espace de
convergence y compris avec les grands
émergents comme la Chine et l'Inde pour
pousser la Russie à la désescalade face
à la multiplication des crises et des
défis globaux le G20 ne veut pas de la
guerre
que le G20 ne veut pas de chantage
nucléaire qu'il juge une admissible et
que si le G20 est avant tout une
instance de coopération économique tous
ces membres affirment qu'il reposent
aussi sur le respect du droit
international Claude blanche mais
beaucoup parlé du rôle de la Chine qui
manifestement un discours qui est un peu
changé est-ce que le fait que la Russie
soit isolée en fait c'était assez clair
à la fin de ce G20 est-ce que
effectivement ça aussi un impact sur
l'entourage de Vladimir Poutine
peut-être cet isolement
cet état devient pratiquement un état
paria aujourd'hui ce qui était pas le
cas du tout il y a neuf mois sans doute
mais dans ce qu'a dit le président
Macron sur la convergence il est dans
son discours dans la suite de ce
discours il a insisté notamment sur le
fait que le le droit international
devait être respecté et que le droit
international implique la souveraineté
des États et l'intangibilité des
frontières nationales par conséquent et
ça c'est un sujet qui intéresse beaucoup
les Chinois aussi parce que ne serait-ce
que parce que Taï ça fait partie de la
Chine pour eux donc c'est pas un
problème et les les territoires des
Ouigours aussi donc et Poutine
finalement au moment de la négociation
de Minsk en 2000 en lorsqu'il avait
accepté ce processus pour trouver une
solution un point de sortie pour le
dombasque avec accepter que le principe
de la de l'intégrité territoriale des
États soit mentionné
sur l'idée que qui est une idée
simplement qu'il faut respecter les
règles de l'ONU il peut y avoir assez
peut-être un consensus à un moment donné
à condition on sait que voler des instit
a présenté 10 conditions justement
pendant le G20 pour des pour parler de
paix des conditions considérées
inacceptables par la Russie enfin c'est
le retour des frontières avant
l'annexion de la Crimée
en disant ça il ne fait qu'anoncer le
droit international il ne fait
qu'annoncer les règles qui font de l'ONU
qui font de l'organisation de de
que je pense qu'il n'y a humblement
qu'il n'y a que les acteurs extérieurs
pour penser encore qu'il y aura une
issue négociée à cette guerre je pense
que réellement les Russes et les
Ukrainiens au niveau des présidents
Vladimir Poutine et volody myersky ont
clairement dit il n'y a pas de
négociation
volodimeki à qualifié le G20 de G19 dans
ces 10 points et je rejoins ce que vous
disiez à l'instant il n'a fait plus
aucun compromis ni territorial ni
diplomatique ni quel qu'il soit c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui l'Ukraine doit
redevenir l'Ukraine il n'y a plus dans
ses frontières de 91 il n'y a plus un
seul soldat russe qui doit être présent
sur le sol ukrainien on ne s'engage
absolument pas aux conditions qui
exigent Vladimir Poutine préalable
préalablement à son agression à savoir
un statut neutre la des militarisation
etc etc on ne s'engage plus rien on ne
veut plus rien entendre et on veut des
garanties de sécurité de la part de
l'OTAN de la communauté internationale
etc donc a été très clair hier c'était
recevable ils viennent d'annexer 4
régions qui sont légalement au sein du
territoire de la fédération de Russie
pour moi
le virus vont finir par avoir ce qu'il
voulait en quelque sorte c'est-à-dire
cela va se jouer sur le terrain
militaire ils ont dès le début des mêmes
2014 lorsqu'il faisait semblant de
négocier fait savoir que pour eux le
moyen de pression et les leviers étaient
purement militaires et non pas
diplomatique parce que quoi qu'ils en
ont dit ils n'ont jamais appliqué ou
même réellement été dans la réalité de
ce qu'il disait à savoir on ne fait pas
partie de cette guerre ils ont toujours
été dans ce conflit à partir de ce
moment-là ça va se jouer sur le terrain
militaire donc capitulation ou pas de la
Russie ou conflit larvée ou finalement
ré-avancer des Russes à les suivre
l'hiver on ne sait pas mais pour moi
cela va se jouer uniquement sur le
terrain général keno ça va se jouer sur
le plan d'un point de vue militaire
seulement il y aura il faudra qu'il y
ait une capitulation des Russes sur le
terrain
population c'est peut-être excessif mais
il y aura il peut y avoir un retrait un
retrait intelligent des troupes russes
comme il y a déjà eu à Carson c'était le
premier acte militaire intelligent qu'on
fait les Russes on se retire en Kerson
depuis le début de la guerre c'était
mieux pour mieux s'organiser derrière
pour gagner du temps et parce que ils
étaient ils sont en train de former les
les 200 et quelques 260000 hommes qu'ils
ont recruté plus ou moins spontanément
et ils sont en train de les former mais
ça sera pas au-delà de grand chose
puisque les soldats qui ont été
mobilisés
ne sont pas motivés et ils ne sont pas
équipés ils sont équipés de vieux
matériels et ils vont avoir du mal donc
c'est fini on par capituler
parce que ils ont pas les équipements
grands froid qu'on les ukrainiens et un
soldat à moins 15 degrés il meurent
ainsi les pas équipés ils se retireront
stratégiquement
Régis Régis gentil donc pas de place aux
discussions pour l'instant une réaction
peut-être avec ce qui vient d'être dit
oui non je suis plutôt ce que dit Elena
et puis de toute façon c'est souvent le
cas dans la guerre la guerre s'arrête
lorsque les deux protagonistes ou l'un
d'eux ne peut plus ne peut plus
combattre et effectivement on a
l'impression qu'on va vers là ça dit il
y a d'autres d'autres facteurs
effectivement très importants et
notamment effectivement le soutien
occidental militaire à l'Ukraine qui
effectivement capital mais on voit que
s'il continue
la l'Ukraine continuera d'avancer depuis
la contre-offensive qui commence je
crois le 29 août on n'a pas vu une seule
victoire russe depuis ce jour-là et un
constant un constant recul donc
effectivement à ce jour Zelinski est en
position de force pour dire bah on
continue et sur la question de la Crimée
effectivement je crois qu'il faut quand
même rappeler que la Crimée est
ukrainienne et c'est pas moi qui le dis
ce sont les Russes qui l'ont dit en 91
en reconnaissant les frontières des
républiques soviétiques et pendant bien
des années d'ailleurs ça a pas été
questionné politiquement et donc
javinsky veut en faire un point un point
d'honneur c'est sans doute pour le
moment plutôt
une manière de poser les choses plutôt
que c'est sans doute un objectif de
guerre de guerre réel mais on en est pas
pas encore là on voit que la progression
est malgré tout assez lente mais je
crois que c'est ça que je veux dire veut
dire Zelinski effectivement et puis par
ailleurs la Chine pour reprendre la
discussion que vous aviez effectivement
très important on voit bien je crois que
c'est ça souffre pas la discussion du
jour où ça marquant
mi-septembre monsieur enfin le
manifestement le président chinois a
fait savoir Monsieur Poutine qu'il était
pas d'accord avec notamment les menaces
nucléaires on s'est aperçu qu'après
monsieur Poutine n'a plus agité cette
menace pour agir Régis résidenté d'avoir
été avec nous directement
Elena Volochine et puis à vendredi bien
sûr merci général keno Merci à VOUS
Claude Claude blanche maison merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivi restez
avec nous sur France 24